praise Satan my Sabrina fans April can't
come fast enough because we have the
first season to trailer for chilling
Adventures of Sabrina and it looks
friggin awesome so we're gonna get right
into what this teaser might have in
store for us so if you haven't seen it
yet I've left a link in the description
and come on back our first images of
Sabrina fresh out of the shower and the
first thing that comes to my mind is I
hope Nick isn't creeping in the corner
like last time she does a sweet magical
dress change which is an homage to the
original Sabrina I also love how Sabrina
is a fan of David Bowie who obviously
was a warlock Zelda Sabrina if she's
wearing black to be edgy and she
explains it's a new year and if there's
something we know about the end of last
season we know this is a new Sabrina
indeed check out the flowers and bunny
rabbits in the corner here which hint
that it's around Easter time which would
totally line up with its April release
date as well as how the show has done an
amazing job at tracking the seasons
remember we still have a Christmas
episode to get to Ambrose is just being
Ambrose that dude is always eatin
breakfast now I think this is really
cool the editors here of juxtaposed to
school dances to show that sabrina is
straddling the mortal and human realms
the first year at Baxter high and the
other at the witch Academy but that's
not the only thing Sabrina is straddling
holy Jesus is this a high school dance
or an Abercrombie party but focus here
in Sabrina with Nick which leads me to
believe this is earlier on in the season
before she likely gets back with Harvey
kinkle now we're at a much more subdued
dance and notice here what looks like a
wolf pelt we'll get to the wolves in a
second for those of you who don't know
they're performing what's called a maple
dance which historians believe
originated as a pagan German fertility
dance and the women are the ones holding
the ribbons while the men sit and are
danced around miss Wardwell is back and
it looks as though she's preparing for a
Valentine's dinner holding a Native
American or African doll which is
clutching a spear Sabrina arrives back
at Baxter high to find Harvey taking off
Roz's glasses almost as if he's about to
kiss her as Sabrina watches scandalous
we then get an image of a full moon and
if you guys recall from my Sabrina
ending explain video which if you
haven't seen get on it one of my
theories for this season is that
werewolves might play a big role
especially when we see dr. servers his
eyes at the end of the sea
and the fact he's named after a
three-headed dog we then see Amber's
partaking in some sort of ritual with a
horn
Salem hissing and yes it's possible
we'll hear Salem talk this season and
Sabrina being chased by bats now some
people have pointed this out but I think
it's a bit too on-the-nose
but it's possible they are vampires
again I don't think we have enough
evidence for that yet
we have Sabrina here holding hands and
performing a ritual with what could
either be Faustus or Nik but we do see
Faustus right after with those
beautifully manicured fingernails this
is followed by The Weird Sisters a
janitor casually mopping up blood
kidding it's probably some sort of paint
or Jam and he'll they're getting ready
to go out on the town
could she be going on a date with dr.
Cerberus we then have this image who I'm
90% sure is Nick but look what he's
wearing they look like human clothes
what do you guys think is this someone
new and of course this is followed by
Sabrina kissing kinkle Sabrina you
naughty minx
but when Sabrina pulls out this knife we
get even more hints of a werewolf season
a the knife could be silver which could
kill a werewolf be she's wearing a red
cape like Little Red Riding Hood and see
oh is that too on the nose
she then takes a gas canister to the
halls of Baxter high and is whispered to
by the Dark Lord who says do it and then
worst of all we have to wait until April
5th renew season to come out but don't
worry December 14th the Sabrina
Christmas episode comes out and I'll be
doing a full breakdown of that so make
sure you're subscribed you like share
smash every possible button except
dislike and stay tuned until next time